I who already didn't very much because I
couldn't very much because I can't enjoy
it all the time can no longer drop
doctor's orders I cannot again it is bad
for my health it will not do me any good
- I want you to debate in the collar oh
wait a minute
was that a but I heard would you rather
the family with Samuel Jackson or family
with Vin Diesel is this even a question
who wouldn't want to family with samuel
l.jackson I'd go for beauty pie first
you know get whatever stringy I could
pull off of his and then I'd probably go
for Jack next and then kind of suede Dan
and filled be on my side me like I would
chew we're kings of this island together
now onto the second bathroom and shower
equipped with a camera that you can see
markiplier is beautiful hey guys I just
wanted to say honestly and truly you
guys so much for supporting me
would you rather swallow three
jawbreakers or swallow a footlong ooh if
you swallow the footlong one that'd be
really hot and sexy but to it break into
shards into your throat maybe and that
wouldn't be good at all okay I don't
know I've never in my life until next
time okay Baba Bailey
oh you later Billy later Oh Billy way
later would you rather be deaf and have
no or be blind and have no I don't know
it all depends on whether or not oh man
but if I like to be able to see but if I
have no and how will I masturbate I'm
gonna feel good right over the ah right
over my oh it hurts already I think I
didn't put the odds drizzling all over
my crotch
didn't even do that much eyes red
already Jesus
ah from the best I wish I could more I'm
not to my head